- This is huge!
Sorry, I'm just.
- You look great, it's been a long time.
- Holy schmoly.
- That's right, holy shmoly, that's right.
That would be the TV
version of the phrase.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We first met on December 10th, 1991.
You were what, 10 or 11?
- I think I had just turned 11.
- [Jay] Yeah, that's right.
- Yeah, I had just turned 11.
And yeah, seeing you today,
yeah, it's bringing back a lot.
(Anna laughing)
- Now, I remember back then,
you said you wanted to
be a paleontologist.
A very serious young woman, yeah.
I'm going to be a paleontologist.
- Yeah, yeah, I did.
- How'd that work out?
(Anna laughing)
- I haven't even played a paleontologist.
So, I suppose I still have
some dreams to come true.
- Now, you have kids of your own now.
- I do.
- Okay, now, I read something.
They're fascinated by seeing you cry?
As an actress, you mean,
is that what it is?
- No, they haven't seen my work yet.
Yeah, a lot of the work I do
is not
- Not for kids.
- Suitable for children.
- Okay,
No, it's not porn.
Please, could we.
- Yeah, it's not creepy.
Like, chill out.
(audience laughing)
- It just came off bad.
(Anna laughing)
- Yeah.
- Yeah, no, it's just, you know.
Grownup themes.
- No, it's adult themes.
- Yeah, but, you know, they like to see
when I definitely will cry at a movie.
- [Jay] Right.
- And, usually, there are certain movies.
What comes to mind is there's
a certain song in Mulana
and there's a certain
sequence in Inside Out
where, basically, if I
just hear the music, I'll.
- [Jay] Really?
- I'll just, it's Pavlovian at this point.
- Right.
Now, is it just cartoons you cry at, or?
- Yeah, I mean.
I suppose I've definitely
cried at Sound of Music.
I've cried at, I cry in
movies, I cry watching movies.
But they get very excited to, like,
to kind of confirm their
suspicion that this will happen.
You know?
- Really?
- I'm like a scientific
experiment at that point.
- You see, I would cry, like,
when a car crashes in Fast and
Furious, because I like cars.
- Because you like cars!
- Look at that Chevy!
- No, it's true.
It's true.
- Chevy's.
- And those cars appreciate your love.
- That's right, that's right.
- Yes.
(Anna laughing)
- So, do your kids
understand joking and lying,
and fake crying and?
- I mean, this is something
that I think still,
I mean, this is what I tell my kids too,
I'm like grownups are
still trying to figure out
the difference between lying
and joking and honesty.
- Between lying and joking?
- Yeah, my eldest daughter
asked me that one day.
She was like, mom, what's the difference
between a lie and a joke?
And I really had to think
about it, because I don't like
dishonesty in my own life.
- Right, sure.
- I'm not cool with it.
And, so, I really wanted
to make sense of that.
But I have to make sense
of that for myself first,
before I tell her.
So, I don't know, I was like,
lying, when somebody lies,
they don't intend to tell you the truth.
And that's not fair, right?
Somebody doesn't get to know
the truth when you don't.
- You see, my favorite are
kids doing that kind of thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, I had a kid
write me a letter once.
He said, dear Mr. Leno, he was about 12.
He said, I told my friends you're my uncle
and on Sundays we go for
rides in your Lamborghini.
And he goes on to this whole thing.
- What?
- He said, could you
pick me up at my house.
- [Anna] Poppy!
- And give me a ride to school,
so my friends won't know I'm a liar.
- Oh, but you are.
- I said, but you are, you are a liar!
And you are a liar!
(Anna laughing)
I just loved the fact
that he wrote me a letter.
So, I called his parents
and I said, listen,
you know, when a old guy picks
up your kid in a Italian car.
- Yeah, yeah, that's not okay.
- I said, your son wants me
to give him a ride to school.
He's like, okay.
- So, I go to the house, I pick him up.
We pull up to the school,
you know, the Lamborghini's
got the doors that come up like this.
He goes, bye, uncle Jay.
And I go, okay, I'll see you later.
As I pull out, I hear a kid
go, he really is his uncle.
Now I'm like, oh, what a liar I am.
- Exactly, what did I just do?
- Yeah, exactly.
- You're a complicit.
- I am complicit in
this child, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- He's now in federal prison.
I don't know what happened to the kid.
- I'm sure!
(Anna laughing)
- Speaking of lying, your
new show, Inventing Anna,
this is a true story, isn't it?
- Yes, this is a true story.
- Because I remember this.
- And then we fictionalized some of it.
My character is a fictionalized version
of the author of the article
on which it is based.
Jessica Pressler, but my
character's name is Vivian Kent.
We fictionalized some other things,
but we're very honest about that,
we say it right up front.
- Right, right.
- But yes, most of it is
definitely based on fact,
based on everything that was
investigated in our article.
The story about Anna Delvey.
- But what's the basis
of the story, she pretends to be?
- She was a young, she
is still a young woman
who managed to scam her way all
the way to the top of, like,
New York society and really
get all of these perks,
and I'm the reporter who
investigates her story the whole way.
- It's hard to believe
an attractive young woman
could scam men, I wonder how.
(audience laughing)
- You know.
- It's so odd, it's an unusual story.
- So, many people have seen
this program, so, you know,
and, so, I would suggest,
it's fun to watch it again
and imagine her as an older male.
And it's not that confusing anymore
what she's doing to people.
You know what I mean?
- Right, yeah, yeah.
- It's like, oh, yeah, she
buys them things and then,
she buys them clothes and then tells them
that they look horrible in it, okay, yeah.
He's trying to control you, right?
But it's like, because it comes from her,
and she's young and she's personable,
it really did kind of cast a spell
on those for whom it was happening.
- And she got away with
it for a long time, right?
- Yeah, and there's always
the question of, oh,
if she had just gotten her
funding for her startup,
would she have been called a
genius or called a scammer?
- Right, right.
- But, you know, yeah, you
gotta wonder those things.
And the idea is, would she
just find the next con?
You know, you never know.
Because that's not how it turned out.
- That's kind of like Elizabeth Holmes
or that Theranos deal.
- Right, it's really similar.
- So many, because it was a young girl,
everybody wanted to believe, 19,
and let's give this kid a chance.
- Yeah, yeah.
And there's also that aspect of, like,
of wanting to be the one
who found the next Mozart.
Do you know what I mean?
Oh, I'm the one who saw it, and
I'm the one who fostered it.
And, yeah, everybody's playing
on their own ego at that point, so,
better to listen to one another.
- It's on Netflix right now.
So, check it out.
- Yeah, it is, go watch.
- It's called Inventing
Anna and check it out.